Now we're going to talk about animation editors
and features within the engine.
There are several animation editors or sub-editors,
as we like to call them, within the engine.
I'm just going to give you a quick overview of those,
and then once we get into the engine,
we'll explore it a little bit more depth.
We have the animation blend space editor,
which is a great way to control your animations,
especially your real-time animations,
have them set up in order to,
let's say, blend several different types
of animations like a walk to a lean,
a lean to a right lean, a left lean,
perhaps lean back as they're walking.
This is where you would do that.
Now the animation blueprint editor,
we won't be diving into that too much,
but that is where you can set up
very specific animation blueprints,
as the name does state,
to set up various effects and how things can happen.
This is where you could put a live link
through your control rig, many powerful things,
and it works very much like our blueprint editor itself
within the engine.
Then we have the animation sequence editor,
which is where you can take some existing animations
and add more curves to it, make some notifications.
And we will explore this one just a little bit
to create our own little custom animation.
Now there's a new thing with the animation mode
that is activated when you have a control rig
within your scene.
So you will need a control rig to activate it.
You can pull it up, but you won't be able to use it
unless there's an active control rig in your scene.
So some of the things you'll see is the poses,
tweens, snapper, trails, and even a pivot.
So you can customize your pivot.
These are all very powerful,
and I've included a link as well that you can reference
to further learn about these really powerful tools
that have been added within the engine.